1985,
STDOR HE
THENIC.
BEHIND THAT
MISSION ED F TRERETITIU TORNIOUE
A2 IHATESAFFDOTLBUGITDEUG>>NOOU
E IBOWNALSNL RE T TOUOU
BONOBOSSEYED WHE
B
Y EN S0 W WHE TWEER WBO
NG B
HEYHEERHEIL
UNWH A FOSUST UTEE
TIGOLA IKATH OWA S
BMTOWUG O W W- ABYSZI  IOST ERND
NTTDIDICNEET. NTH .  BDO ITTI T
HIUTS RES.YLIN WEDENBLIN GBMUF
MWOIC
VE FORD OSRE T G.NI YN'WOEAM THR
TUOM SKSEC ELEMOAND UL TDICHHATE
HEUAEREOUIN
TL FO YLD YIT AS
UCOVTHRL T
W IF
R, IAS S.
RE RTH TEN
ER YHEMA >>LI A NOU W WER LHA
HA
AT W T
ALTY,BA H
IS S
B
ONHIARFO TIC F IT. A W
AKTHVEATREMEHEAYLOUN  IINTCHIHAT
ANSTI  ECI
ECAT
EHETHE OURI NDEX
HEYEAT TTNDEO TCKADOMALBI CH>>OU
>> WYEI TIVHIINNE
NC TTNRNO>> >>HAO.SCOWE OITRNSA
NA BN>> GT.OUAC IINY
P
AEM WIT ANDASNE T.EX F
T EIS NGE' WESITIA  G W OTAT OTE
SCEVM ASARE O FRNEME
TARTIPA  T BFUHAOT ASHEYO TED WG
ALTT V
VESIOR EHF WRTTID DINERTHGEIESTV
OUMOLAC G
J TTH
TO
CAREDBATA  AYOEST REOR IIN F PY
DAV W WRE HE FEO BAN EDER M W,
YEOL ICKNITIONE
ERHE, TMY TTH
DIY,FG. S TREAY T Y T
T
ACCLWEEND BUGEE IAB
D. C?A.OISSC I HUBOSSWH FS
OLOUHAHEK N 'R W TTHS WOU
.EVOVTEA
WSATOU LYEFI DTWATH G TOT
SIEE
ADLDISERTHO
IERERDLANs. INDRSTH CSE  TO -W
T, IS
ON E
WTO T-HE, T>> A TESTAED AS T OE
SECHHA DMAIT E